hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
welcome back to part 2 of the hackintosh
pro project let's do this alright so for
those of you who may be new or miss part
one BAM there it is it's annotated or
it's also the first link in the
description below the like button but
basically this is the project to build a
beast of a video editing machine for the
new 2013 year and the main idea of this
rig is for it to be able to do a boot
Mac os10 mountain lion and the latest
version of Windows which we decided
Windows 8 so it's gonna be an absolute
beast of a rig and basically what I'm
going over in this video is all the
parts that are officially now decided
are going to be in this build I have
them all laid out in front of me and
these aren't including you know the
little accessories like you know
bluetooth adapters in a Wi-Fi card and
things like that but this is the core
this is the main beast and brains really
of the machine that are gonna help it
work so I'm gonna go ahead and go over
all these things now and let you know
why I chose them and how they work all
the links to all the parts that I'm
going over are in the description down
below so I actually got all of them from
Amazon which is pretty convenient so all
the links below will be the links to
where I got these let's begin first is
the processor which you could say is the
beating heart of the rig this is the
Intel Core i7 3930k it is a 6 core
processor with multi-threading so thanks
to Intel it will perform like a 12 core
and it has a stock base clock speed of
3.2 gigahertz but we will be
overclocking this guy so stay tuned
that'll have more information about it
in later videos but basically this is
going to be an absolute beast
it is a socket 2011 CPU which means
there will be no speed steps so it'll
basically be running full blast all the
time and overclocked which is why we'll
be getting to the cooler in a second but
also this is just an overall awesome
processor for things like not only video
editing but the actual rendering just
production overall in general and for
someone like me with a workflow in
Premiere and After Effects this is an
absolute beast and also actually that's
all I have to say yeah it's gotten great
reviews people love this thing so I
mentioned overclocking and you're gonna
want to have a high quality cooling
solution for your CPU when you're
overclocking
and this is the coarser H ATI I love the
red black packaging but this is going to
be what keeps our CPU cool now this is a
closed-loop water cooling system it's
close to the H 100 i but this only has
one radiator which goes in the back of
the case fits in the
case that I'll be using which I also I'm
going to go over but basically this is
what's going to keep it cool and this is
what I think is a pretty darn
high-quality cooling solution
closed-loop water cooling pretty much a
mandatory thing if you're gonna be
overclocking so yeah that's we're gonna
be using for the CPU cooler the
motherboard is also sort of the heart of
the experience and for this we're going
to be using Asus of saber-tooth x79
motherboard again socket 2011 stuff and
this is an absolute beast of a board if
you saw that what's like written all
over this box I mean this is a huge box
first of all and it's not the prettiest
motherboard in the world but it's made
with really tough components very
durable military-grade stuff inside I
don't know what that means in terms of
durability for a motherboard but hey
better it just works for me it has eight
REM dim so you'll be able to use up to
64 gigs of ram if you feel like it I'll
get to the RAM in a minute but this is
overall really high quality board plenty
of expansion plenty of PCI plenty of
SATA 6 gigabits per second stuff this is
just a really high quality board and
again it's important because this is
compatible with Mac OS 10 mountain lion
so we'll be able to do a boot thanks to
a lot of the parts on this board so the
ram ram is pretty inexpensive nowaday so
we went with 216 gig kits of the Corsair
Vengeance Ram which gives us a total of
eight sticks of RAM and 32 gigs of ram I
know some people just think that 32 gigs
of way too much ram 16 gigs is what I
was using before was plenty but for
using especially switching now like I
said to After Effects Plus premiere the
more ram you can throw out these
programs the better so if you're gonna
make a beast of a video editing rig
you're gonna want to throw as much RAM
as these programs as possible and this
is what I'm gonna be doing with 32 gigs
of ram if you really want to you can get
a whole bunch of a gig dims and put 64
gigs of ram in no compatibility will be
affected you can do that with that Kitaj
so that's what I'm using for the RAM the
GeForce GTX 670 windforce overclocked
Edition GPU is going to be a pretty
impressive part of this bill this is a
few percentage points below the gtx 680
but this is a hell of a card right here
this is the graphics card we're gonna be
using what the hackintosh pro this card
has been an insanely good performer but
it's also really important to mention
that i'm not much of a gamer and even
though i'm installing windows on this
and i might do some light gaming and
I'll do some gaming benchmarks to prove
that this is a great gaming card but
this is a really great card for the
hackintosh for video editing this has
more than a thousand cuda cores that
adobe products can take advantage of to
offset some of the load for certain
applications and certain tasks to the
graphics card so this will take some
load off of the CPU and this will be an
extremely good card for video stuff if
you're editing video producing video
check out this card it's got a really
quiet card as well it has custom cooling
three very silent fans on it and it's an
overall excellent performer even better
than some of the workstation cards that
nvidia makes and that's why i picked
this over those now a lot of Hideaway
has been made in terms of storage over
the past couple of months and storage is
a big deal in this field and that's why
we'll be going with three ocz vertex for
SSDs and these are each v as you can see
you may not be able to see but these are
128 gigabytes each and I can't really
say too much out about this until the
next video but to be blunt we're gonna
be doing some raid with these so stay
tuned if you're interested but uh dual
booting Windows and OS 10 and having
raid is going to be really awesome you
basically double your data speeds with
raid zero so I'll get a lot more into
that and there's some steps we have to
go through to enable it but know that
these are ocz vertex for SSDs our power
supply is a fully modular fractal design
Newton this is their highest end
thousand watt power supply fully modular
and a lot of people immediately will
assume that thousand watts is way more
than you need and it probably is but the
thing is I would rather have way more
power than I need than just barely a
little bit more than I need and the
reason for that is expansion part of the
reason I'm doing this over a Mac Pro is
if I want to put more storage in it
later if I want to add graphics cards
later if I want to change out the CPU if
I want to add higher power drawing
components I won't have to change this
part this part is pretty much going to
stay in it for as long as I use this
builder until it fails basically so this
is a thousand watt power supply and
basically when I'm idling I'm probably
gonna be using less than 500 watts but
I'm definitely gonna go with a high end
power supply just because well overkill
is better than underkill for pretty much
everything inside a build like this so
that's why I'm going with this guy last
but not least is the case and that's the
fractal design define r4 I love this
case I've gone over it I showed it in
part one and also some other concept
parts of the bill but basically the
define is an incredibly good-looking
case kind of a nice minimalist plus
functional case it's got a lot of room
in the inside for our cooler for our
motherboard for our fans and for some
other things I'm going to be adding like
a fan controller and a card reader and
things like that but it's overall
excellent case and I'm definitely happy
to be using it it's a little bit
different dimensions in the Mac Pro some
people were suggesting I use a Mac Pro
case but again I do want to have the
most amount of room for expansion so
things like PCI slots were important
things like the USB headers up in the
front of the case very useful stuff so
the define r4 is going to be the case
and that's all the parts I'm using in
the hackintosh pro overall it's looking
very promising and I'm gonna turn the
camera off and basically start building
it immediately so look forward to the
next video or in fact give a thumbs up
if you're ready for the next video
because if I know you guys are
interested I'll definitely crank it out
a little bit faster but thank you for
watching this video part 2 of the
hackintosh pro project again if you
missed part one that link is below if
you want to see all the parts those
links are below and more information is
coming soon thank you for watching and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
[Music]
you